>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> An Introduction to BARD Express.
>> Karen Keninger: Hi,
I'm Karen Keninger,
the Director of the National
Library Service for the Blind
and Physically Handicapped.
We call it NLS.
I am excited to announce our
latest development, BARD Express.
BARD Express is an application
you use on your personal computer.
BARD Express simplifies
the browsing and searching
for available talking books and
magazines on the NLS Braille
and Audio Reading Download
site, known as BARD.
It also manages audio materials
you have downloaded and takes care
of unzipping and copying
them to a cartridge
with the click of a button.
The BARD site contains nearly
90,000 books, magazines,
and instructional music scores
in audio and braille formats,
and the collection grows every day.
With BARD Express you can search
for audio titles by subject
and by series, and you can browse
the audio magazine collection
or the recently added
and most popular lists.
Before you can use BARD Express,
there are three things you need
to have in place: First, you
must be registered with a Braille
and talking book library
in the NLS network.
If you aren't registered, but
you think you might qualify
for this service because you can't
read standard print due to a visual
or physical disability, check
out the eligibility
requirements at www.loc.gov/nls.
Second, you must establish
a BARD account.
Only registered NLS patrons
are eligible for BARD accounts.
Go to http://NLSBARD.loc.gov
and follow the instructions
to set up your account.
And third, you must download
the BARD Express application
from the BARD website.
It's free and available
to all BARD users.
Next, log into BARD Express with
your BARD user name and password.
You'll only need to do this the
first time you use the application.
BARD Express has ten buttons on
the Main Screen - "Bookshelf,"
"Wish List," "Preferences," "Manage
Devices," and several browsing
and searching options
mentioned earlier.
Use the search and browse buttons to
locate audio titles you wish to read
with your digital talking
book machine.
When you find a title that
you want simply select it
and use the download button
to put it on your bookshelf.
From the main menu, choose bookshelf
and then select the title
that you wish to read.
Then use the copy button to
copy it to the cartridge.
BARD Express does the rest.
No more unzipping book files.
No more searching for lost
titles on your computer.
BARD Express manages your downloads,
takes care of unzipping
files downloaded from BARD,
and facilitates the transfer of
audio materials to an external drive
for playing in the digital
talking book machine.
When the transfer is complete,
disconnect your cartridge or drive
from the computer, insert it
into your talking book
machine and enjoy your book!
BARD Express also allows you to
access and download audio titles
from your personal BARD wish
list using the wish list button.
Repeat the sequence: select the
title, activate the download button,
return to the Bookshelf, copy to
your cartridge, and enjoy your book.
The process of searching
for, downloading,
and transferring reading
materials has never been easier!
BARD Express works with JAWS,
WindowEyes, and NVDA screen readers.
That concludes our overview of the
BARD Express application for PCs.
For instructions on using
the various features
of this application see the online
BARD Express How-To Video Series.
Happy reading!
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.